now there you go you've got that on
there let's draw another one draw
another one exactly the same
okay now what we're going to do on this
little set of axis here is we're going
to plot
a graph or plotting graphs
okay what's a graph all it means is some
kind of relationship between
x and y just the relationship between x
and y
so let's start thinking remember i said
to you x and y could be anything
they could be like um temperatures or
times or
money for instance let's think about
money because money is money's easy to
work with okay
let's consider you know what if x were
you know number of things you sold
okay uh what do you want to sell today
something not too expensive please
sorry mandarin mandarins sure
mandarins actually if it's mandarins
i i better make a number of kilograms
because you don't really buy
oh yeah can i have one mandarin please
let's spend your money
uh we we priced them by kilograms so x
is the number of kilograms sold
okay and let's make why well you know
how much was the how much was the cost
okay how much was the cost now let's
think about this okay
uh i think a pretty normal cost would be
a pretty good cost me two dollars a kilo
that was a kilo not bad let's let's make
it two dollars for the
simplicity of numbers okay two dollars a
kilo
okay so what we might say is well what
if i sold
one kilogram one kilogram okay
one kilogram
well that would correspond to two
dollars right
because it's just two dollars a kilo
okay now look
our x number this is the kilograms okay
so this
is going to be our x in a second and
this two dollars right this is our
vertical thing so that is our y
okay now every time like i could do what
about two kilograms what about 15
kilograms and on and on and on
i could keep on writing kilograms and i
could keep on writing dollars
right but when you do this for a while
you're like all i really need is the one
and the two
or the two and the four whatever the
numbers are so i'm going to write this
like this this is my short hand
okay these are my coordinates right
an x of one matches up with a y of two
and i can draw this on let's do it um
don't draw it too big put your one in
fairly close okay let's make one there
and
two there you can see that yeah and x is
like always best in every single
situation yes
absolutely
okay now um yes
yes another way to think about it is
horizontal first
vertical second whatever they are and we
always call them x's and y's like it's
the most common thing
okay so yeah it's alphabetical okay
so all right now yeah sorry question
yeah yeah let's do that let's do that so
sorry there's my point
okay and put a nice nice decent dot on
it and we'll label it
i'm going to label it one comma two
okay there it is i've plugged it next
one
um you don't always have to but i want
us to know what it is and we're going to
join the dots
okay uh we are we'll talk about them in
a second
again let's do another simple example
let's go two
kilograms right clearly if you sell two
two grams you'll make one right
so i'm going to write that as two
comma four okay so there's kind of like
a combination of factors here number one
when you see the brackets
sorry i should say parentheses when you
see the parentheses when you see the
comma
that's what indicates to you aha these
two numbers
they match together they're coordinates
okay whenever you see a pair of numbers
in that way
so 2 comma 4. i can plot that onto my
set of axes
as well two would be the next one along
right and then i'll go up three four
so there you go two comma four
now i'll just do i'll just do one more
okay uh
and we don't have to do three six we
could do anything we liked right
uh let's go up to let's go up to four
because
my graph is not going to go any further
unfortunately
ah we'll talk about negatives in a
second i will get to another promise
four kilograms two dollars a kilo eight
bucks okay so again
there's your set of coordinates okay
so plotted on i have just barely got
enough space to do it
six seven eight so maybe yours is a bit
too small that's okay
right so i've got that there three
four there you go
okay now here's where it starts to get
useful
okay um graphs like this are used all
the time to predict things
to predict things right so these three
points
uh they're what we call collinear
they're all a straight line and you can
join that up get your ruler
okay and i want you to line it up along
these three points if you did it
accurately they'll all fit together okay
let's try it
okay so it's it's a it's a dot-to-dot
thing right so here's what i get
now let's notice a couple things like
this number one
it predicts some things for instance if
you've drawn it right like
i have can you see how this graph
it passes through a very important point
at the origin right lots of graphs past
the origin now what does that mean
what does that mean this point here is
0-0
i mean if i don't sell any kilograms of
battery is you'll make no money
of course that makes sense okay ah now
we can keep going
what happens over here these values here
they're negative exactly right so for
instance the one i've just drawn in and
i'd love for you to draw one as well
this is negative three okay now what
would that mean
in this context this is about kilograms
of maybe maybe it's like look i bought
i bought 20 kilos of um mandarins to the
shop to sell
and someone stole three kilos oh my gosh
someone stole free killing
that's right so i'm outraged right now
what does that mean
for me in terms of money
i've lost ah now have a look
if you've drawn it right this should be
negative
six down here okay so i'm six dollars in
the red
what a pain okay hopefully i'll make up
enough other money to
go yeah it's it's
i i won't lose too much sleep over i
promise
so there's the first thing okay the
second thing is
see how i drew some points okay and then
i joined them all up right
down there but there's actually there's
an infinite series of points along here
i don't have to just pick
like easy whole numbers i can pick we
know ridiculous numbers like
3.7 7.4
that's going to be on there you can
measure it out what's that refer to yeah
are you going to ask something else just
quickly before you like what what does
this mean
it means if i don't sell a round number
someone comes up and
they plonk it on the scales and it comes
to 3.7 kilograms
right i'll sell that for seven dollars
40.
simple okay yeah
okay good and it works right all of
these points like there's
an infinite number of points all joined
together there
okay now last thing to mention on this
okay this graph it's unified by a rule
the x's and y's have this connection
okay namely that
every y value is exactly
double every x value right
i mean because it's two dollars a kilo
right
so if i put in an x value and then i
double it that'll give you the y value
right
so this here this is violet important
you should write it down and
up there next to the line you've drawn
this is
the equation because you know it's got
an equal sign in it
this is the equation of the graph so
that's
the rule yeah if you like instead of
saying equation you can say
this is the rule the rule that binds all
of these points together